[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu israelis
welt heute gibt es eine österreichische
spezialität wir werden nämlich
tafelspitz zu bereiten
und zwar wird es aus rindfleisch
hergestellt tafelspitz ist auch ein teil
vom rind und das ganze haben wir in wien
gegessen und zwar wirklich super lecker
dort wird ganz traditionell in einer
brühe angerichtet und dazu kommen dann
verschiedene beilagen
ich zeige euch mal was wir dafür
benötigen dafür verwende ich einen
tafelspitz der hat etwa ein kilo bis
eineinhalb ich habe ich nur drei rinder
marx knochen drei rinderknochen salz
pfeffer und piment laubblätter und hier
drüben das gemüse da habe ich einfach
wurzelgemüse petersilie sellerie
zwiebeln petersilienwurzel und karotten
und jetzt richten wir erst einmal die
brühe das fleisch muss nämlich ein paar
stunden und garen und darf man eben auch
schön ziehen und den derzeit kammer dann
später die beilagen zu bereiten ich sehe
jetzt erstmal die zwei zwiebeln das
fleisch und die rinderknochen die habe
ich jetzt bereits waren gewaschen und
nochmal abgedruckt und es ist auch ganz
wichtig dass ihr auf jeden fall
rindermarkt knochen und rinderknochen
verwendet einfach für den kräftigen
geschmack sonst regt macht die kräftige
note gar nicht mit rein sind ihr die
zwiebeln und erhitzt den topf und brate
die zwiebeln erstmal richtig scharf an
bist du unten fast schon schwarzen
dadurch bekommen die nämlich kräftigen
geschmack und die werden jetzt auch mit
der schale verwendet so bekommt die
brühe dann ihre farbe
[Applaus]
kann ich die zwiebeln wir da rausnehmen
netz bereits jetzt gießt sich hier das
wasser jetzt haben wir schon mal den
kräftigen geschmack von dem zwiebel dann
die rinderknochen drin der markt machen
das jetzt auch gleich noch mittelmeer
wasser rein also schon so etwa drei
liter und natürlich auch tafelspitz
jetzt gebe es hier die lorbeerblätter
dazu hat meine mama immer zu jedem
fleischgerichte zugegeben dann etwas
demand und einen puffer körper und jetzt
ist ganz wichtig dass das fleisch nicht
kocht wasser einfach sc wird das heißt
ich lasse jetzt langsam erhitzen und
dann wirklich nutzen und so darf das
jetzt zweieinhalb stunden lang sieben so
wird das fleisch schön zart gibt den
geschmack an die brühe ab und die zeit
nutze ich jetzt einfach kurzum das
gemüse so ein bisschen klein zu
schneiden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wichtig beim tafelspitz ist dass er auf
keinen fall kocht sondern einfach nur in
der brühe bietet nach zweieinhalb
stunden gebe ich jetzt das gemüse mit
dazu jetzt darf das gemüse noch mal eine
stunde mit garen und einfach auch so ein
bisschen ziehen
das habe ich jetzt auch schon dazu
gegeben und kann jetzt die beilagen
machen
wir machen jetzt klassisch die
kartoffeln als beilage sauerrahm um dann
noch den apfel meerrettich zum servieren
verwende ich etwas sauberer schnitt laut
medien kochende kartoffeln zwei äpfel
zitronen meerrettich salz und pfeffer
für die kartoffel nehme ich jetzt eine
grobe reife wird es noch ist bei einem
chat mit kempter habe ich auch
kartoffeln gerieben und dann schön
knusprig ausgebracht ausgebacken und
genau so machen wir es hier auch dem so
habe ich es auch in flacher gegessen in
wien und es war echt super lecker also
kartoffeln schreiben und habe nutze ich
jetzt die schale einfach mit weil sie
ohne kartoffeln sind und die schale auf
der bühne durch die kartoffel bekommen
hat echt mit tollen kampf
jetzt nämlich die kartoffeln und drückte
so ein bisschen aus und einige der
zwischenzeit auch schon mal ein bisschen
fett in der pfanne erhitzen einfach bis
in sonnenblumenöl zum beispiel oder
frittiert
[Applaus]
im heißen fett werden jetzt die
kartoffeln frittiert für etwa fünf bis
acht minuten bis sich ein golf hause und
das ganze bei mittlerer stufe und in der
zwischenzeit mache ich schon mal den
apfel merit
[Applaus]
auf den apfel gebe ich direkt
zitronensaft damit er nicht braun wird
und jetzt ist noch der meerrettich dran
den einfach ein bisschen schälen
ihr könnt natürlich auch mehr hat sich
aus dem glas nehmen
dann habt ihr den immer da wo der
frische da ist einfach ein bisschen dazu
reiben nachgeschmack meerrettich
schalten ist einfach aber ich mag die
schärfe ganz gerne
ich habe ja auch den extra feinen
aufsatz so dass das apfel püree also das
ist absoluter fast fertig ist und dann
einfach nur ein bisschen salz und
pfeffer dran und dann ist schon fertig
für die schnitzel autos einfach den
schnittlauch ein bisschen schneiden und
dann mit der saure sahne ist als pfeffer
würzen
[Applaus]
fertig und jetzt gibt an zu leben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt bin ich fertig die kartoffeln die
werde ich jetzt also falls ihr keine
frittierten kartoffeln machen wollen
dann können wir einfach sagen können zum
beispiel machen
ich kann mir auch nebenher so ein
bisschen auf abkochen und hat dann auch
keine arbeit damit also diese stimmt
bisschen einfacher und vor allem
fettärmer so levrat
du darfst in die küche kommen
traditionell wird so gemacht dass wir
jetzt erstmal die brühe serviert als
ersten gang muss auch sagen dass richtig
hunger weil ich du grad draußen die
pflastersteine legen umzusetzen
und ich sage jetzt probieren und ich
hoffe dass es genauso schmeckt wie bei
muttern nicht also erster gang brühe
ich habe sie ja hallo hab ich das
vielleicht im studio das dürfte eher 7
ich wollte ganz kurz
dann hole ich dass ich raus und dann im
zweiten gang ist nämlich das fleisch
dran der tafelspitz 210 betten eine
leckere brühe gerne richtig cool als
schrecklich klasse ja und hier hat man
ja noch diese rinder marx knochen und
die rinderknochen und des rindermarkt
das schmeckt auch richtig gut also wenn
man da das fed so ein bisschen oder das
mag so wißler rausholt auf ein stück
schwarzbrot das ist lecker und wie
gesagt jahre spielt sich natürlich was
am sonntag also jeden tag als wäre es
gerade unser wochen
wir machen jetzt einfach mal so schmeckt
richtig lecker deswegen würde ich ja
schon fast draußen haben es gibt etwas
was nicht schlecht ist dass ich kann
jetzt nur eine scheibe geben so weil wir
mit den worten ich weiß nicht ob wir
nochmal ist ein gefühl das auch nicht
schlecht ist und zwar ist es in wien ist
aus der pegel müller das legendäre
frankfurter schon besser ich weiß ja
wenn ihr es kennt können darüber
schreiben was ihr jetzt apfel
meerrettich skifliegen hier drin die
haben aber noch keine fliegengitter
haben weil mein mann das mandat wollt ja
wir haben einfach keine zeit zu geben
sauerrahm
ich mache das jetzt da ich meine man
muss jetzt einfach mal probiert und
gerade diese apfel meerrettich welche
zeigen jetzt nur im rücken vom messer
drauf das ist schon richtig dass ich
brauche gar nicht schneiden und da
merkst richtig aber wirklich jetzt das
fleisch darf nichts kosten und geschmack
super durch menschliches fleisch wird
der fehler gemacht dass über würzt wird
oder als noch zusätzlich würze reihen
gemacht aber durch das ist natürlich
dass hier die zwiebel mir ganz richtig
genial
falls ihr nicht alles aufessen könnt
dann könnt ihr einfach den tafelspitz
weder hinterbrühl lagern am nächsten tag
wieder wahr machen und essen und der
schmeckt wirklich guten tag zu tag immer
besser das nicht schon mal nämlich ein
größeres stück da haben wir mehrere tage
was davon
afl meerrettich geboren hammer oder ob
wirklich die habe ich auch nicht ich
hatte auch mal frischen meerrettich da
muss ich sagen und dann genau
und genau so war es beim nachrodter
gegessen war super lecker also falls ihr
das rezept gerne mal nachmachen wollt
dann schaut auch sex - blog.de vorbei da
steht noch mal alles ganz genau ich
finde das ist ein richtig tolles menü
nachtisch kann man ja damit opfer knödel
mache zum beispiel da hat man nämlich
eine schöne brühe als er stift gang dann
der tafelspitz als zweiter gang und dann
noch etwas drittes typisch
österreichisches topfenknödel begeistert
coletti richtig genial gemacht wirklich
so richtig order merkt dass die phase
noch waren sie denn wir sind ein teller
dann auf mehr
das ist wahnsinn mach das mal nach ich
will ein ganz ganz tolles sonntags
minimal besitzt bekommt
und da könnte ja ein richtig dicke hose
machen
ok also macht es gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]